[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the funkalicious beats of
lick spear now this game is interesting
because from the preview I thought at
first it was a side-scrolling platformer
and that may still be mutton hell yeah
Hans Helmut Hildebrand evil Johann
halloo sir Norbert Otto rudolf siegfried
who lyric wilhelm bull Kang Albert
andreas through no heater it's Rick
Fritz Kuhn turn Oh Gunter oh I love a
good Gunter Oh God das is okay hey is
this skip rage quit moan if you're just
beginning your lights appearing
adventures in space we recommend you
avoid rage quit mode honestly Wow oh
look here it's another game trying to
tell Gunther how to live his life well
Gunter don't like that very much
Gunter gone straight into reeds quit
mode oh we're thinking yeah I be
thinking you're dumb Achtung you're
about to experience an ancient Germanic
game from the future from the future and
possibly a dimension perpendicular to
your own there's a very high likelihood
that nothing you're about to see will
make it it's our shitty tits
I read fast and I still couldn't blast
through it but good Turk don't need to
read ah
Gunter the ancient German from the
future you know oh hi aku did everybody
else did that was a coup from Samurai
Jack okay
all right
ah sacred mission I like goon turn like
a great honor
[Music]
oh cool the fantastisch
intergalactic rumor powerful is it the
leak smell [ __ ] dude hell to the yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah oh my god goonter how's the
power oh god [ __ ] yeah dude hell yeah
well I mean I think I'll be dead
ah you know that whole dying thing I
don't like the sound of I don't like the
sound of the whole dying thing that
you've got in store for me gasps that's
ancient filled food filed food I don't
speak German I can't even do a German
accent but I mean that's not gonna stop
me from trying when is being bad at
something stop markiplier from being
offensive here we go
meet the nice wizards get at least two
hundred head shots do not use licked
powers leaked lay Oh oh my oh my god
hold the left mouse button to aim oh
[ __ ] well not doing good so far oh that
is so rad I can already tell I'm gonna
be bad at this now you learn how to use
the Tris beer after shooting a spear
press a to split oh I see how we do
hahaha well done now you're ready to die
a lot ah [ __ ]
alright okay who says I'm gonna die oh
they're dead oh jeez
haha okay we're doing good oh my god
there's a lot of ammo boys I can't I
can't even talk oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
getting Guinea a hat
okay take that you I'm assuming Santa's
elves from the bottom there and then ice
giants oh hello I did it though my god
that was impossible but it was awesome
this game is rad oh my god
yeah it'll I gotta remember exactly how
long I have until it's charged up oh my
god is that gonna have a shield was that
good as a Miss forget who oh I gotta get
him right on the tip top of his head oh
my god stay back stay back stay back
Hey Oh God stay back stay back stay back
stay back stay back stay back
oh boy oh boy they're gonna be hard to
hit Hey oh boy oh no oh god that's all
it takes
man no wonder I'm gonna die a lot you're
not ready for this [ __ ] I don't need
this kind of responsibility in my life
ah kun turds gonna get it goon Drew's
gonna get in a million ways it's a weird
rhythm to get into because it shoots on
letting go of the mouse which is not
intuitive to a lot of like shooters that
I've done before so like oh my god why
do those guys have like tiny knives
they'll click lawn gnomes and there's
zombies there no idea what's going on
and it did it start me back in the
beginning again just cuz I died oh my
god let's get to be so horrible Carl boy
oh boy oh boy I can't believe I'm going
for this again I'm not gonna do so well
what's so many of them oh boy I bye bye
I don't care if I miss I just care that
I don't die horribly I wish I could see
like my mouse or something so that I can
know where I'm targeting like in the
distance but it's just like that the
curved triangle trajectory and so it
- I never got why schools are having
such a bad time
oh no no no stay away hey nein
what did I go what what did I do
I miss that one it is you I quote
unquote miss all right yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] there's so many dead
bodies Gunther what have you done
how have you been summoned from the
Future past my god I hope this is
amusing what is it it doesn't seem quite
intelligent for everybody you know here
to just be like running towards the guy
with the horrible spear like why does
this life God even need to fight these
battles here god damn it stop it let me
miss I'm terrible don't you know this
don't you know you picked the wrong
champion Gunther ain't cut out for this
cooter was a Potter not a Harry Potter
let me I'm Harry that's a bad joke okay
cut me up a bit okay we're doing the
okay we're doing all right doing all
right stop stop stop being such an
[ __ ] okay yeah I'm against you right
now oh you popped up at the wrong time
[ __ ] one turd Gunter gotcha with his
leek spear alright who's ready to get
[ __ ] you who is you oh jeez I'm not
ready for that are those dog oohs I
don't need a dog oh god oh god I kind of
want to hit dago's when they're about to
bite my face off
oh jeez oh jeez ah ah Oh No ah [ __ ] it
to the map oh boy good god that's hard
oh I was on number one Oh
can i buy sir I have no LSD I have to
get LSD to be able to do this I have
none cuz I wasn't able to complete a
single damn level well I'm just not good
enough that I get it I have to calm it
down not from ragequit mode all right
[ __ ] Gunther the first let's get tossed
all right hey oz hoping it was gonna be
Helga I don't even need to look at the
other ones Helga East okay come at me
bro I'm ready to die yes soon yes yes
yes
Oh is is this really the difference that
we're getting from this this this is
really the difference this is incredible
man why did I try rage quit mode this is
so much better
hey Olga Olga chin the gullet oh this
must mix is so much better I better I
got it a lot of LSD if I turn on it the
other way the problem is my screen is
very big so it's like it's hard to
visualize the entire arc if the screen
was smaller it might actually work a lot
better hell yeah that was it I had frost
giants pourin up my ass in the very
beginning around and now I got nobody
I'm freakin lonely out here with my lik
spear I mean I could wait for them to
get closer but this is more fun oh it
counted that one I must be awesome - all
right new sunglasses man sorry to ruin
your shades buddy but uh there's the way
rose I'm a way for them to get closer
because I bet I can build up up pretty
honking multiplier cuz I am Margot lair
oh hello it's so much more relaxed I
feel better feel good feel free fun
happy and fresh all right come on give
me something hard don't give me
something hard please oh god not the dog
owes Oh get that dog Oh with a headshot
oh my god why do these guys have shades
I'm gonna book the future but I didn't
think I'd be murdering fashionable frost
giants it's not something that I thought
I would have encountered in this in my
existence practic oh no I finally missed
oh no I got someone in the end there
okay shiftable oh I feel so bad
how did it happen up bring you
Tour Rainier - I know it's not German
but again offensive [ __ ] right here oh
it looks final
let's go bid last one you actually gave
me some threatening something dangerous
something maybe a little bit problematic
for me Oh who's that up there hey do you
think you are who you oh hello thank you
ha ha oh you're knowing anymore
unfortunately for you not for me hey hi
okay go away now Oh dad hey my anybody
else you got two dead sorcerers up there
you know I'm running fancy and free off
too I had freak enough I had I got an A
in accuracy if I was still in the school
that I didn't finish I'd be great uber
oh yeah
hell yeah oh hell E this game is awesome
this is an awesome game oh man everybody
gotta play this game oh and I've got a
great idea
oh I've got a great idea oh I've got a
great idea
oh I've got a great idea but anyway yeah
you guys should totally play this game
see in the [ __ ] buh-bye
I require more and there's among you
battle to the death the winner shall
take my fare the users are the dead to
down a cab
oh is that more challengers I see come
at me then all your dead all your dead
huh
Oh mayor also did well what's that
you're dead oh sorry dad well okay nope
didn't even try you're dead you're gone
Oh another one
sorry the bodies are piling up you're
dead you're dead you're dead you're dead
you're dead you're dead you're dead
you're dead
well careful No Oh God then I'm in the
final vows ha ha
fight fight fight oh hang on wait oh oh
here dad okay right in the nuts
sorry you okay oh sorry
died like the little [ __ ] she was and
now I shall ride into the sunset for
glory and a better light spear leaks